25 years after the fall of the Berlin
Wall
the city is moving beyond its poor but
sexy image and the opulence has exploded
in an unlikely spot this used to be no
man's land between East and West Berlin
and for many property developers it's
become fertile ground to build some
high-end apartments rich in history art
and culture Berlin is increasingly
hosting the actual rich we are selling a
lot of apartments to Russian buyers but
also northern Americans Scandinavians we
got German billionaires coming from
historical industry they want to have
the footprint in a global city so they
buy something in Berlin part of Berlin's
long-awaited post reunification growth
that is finally happening five-star
living but at three or four star prices
this row of townhouses follows the walls
old line for 2.5 million dollars you get
an open ceiling living room and privacy
on demand and eat-in kitchen for stories
a guest room on its own floor private
bath and then a nice little study a
master bedroom a massive bathroom in a
tub with a view a personal gym in the
penthouse and vasana to relax a 7.5
million dollar apartment is the record
for Berlin but the prices are
significantly cheaper than London or
Paris
with the housing shift long-term
residents are being priced out we
recognize that we have I think 10 or 20
evicted today at the moment and 10 years
before we had only one or two eviction
today 50,000 people moved to Berlin last
year alone and rents her up forty three
percent in the past five years but wages
have lagged raising just four percent in
the past three years but the disciples
of deluxe say big dollar buildings spur
growth and they still see open road
ahead looking at the lecture mark in
Berlin it has increased over the last
ten years are definitely increased
between fifty and seventy percent and I
believe that this trend will continue at
probably five percent at least per year
which could mean a ribbon of luxury
where the wall once Ram